alors Laetitia elle a hérité de 30
millions d'euros de dettes de Johnny
Hallyday 30 millions de dettes oui voilà
30 millions de daisses que lui réclame
notamment le fisc et il lui avait le
fils lui avait donné jusqu'au 30 août
pour rembourser une partie de cette
dette qui s'est levée à 13 millions donc
elle a vendu sa maison de Pacific
palissade pour rembourser cette partie
de la dette sauf que elle a racheté une
maison derrière à 5 6 millions et que
donc elle n'a pas pu rembourser toute
cette tête qu'est-ce qu'elle a fait elle
a redemandé au fisc à nouveau délai qui
lui a accordé jusqu'à mi-octobre pour
rembourser toute cette dette sauf que
visiblement elle est assez étranglée
puisque
les royalties il y a des saisies
conservatoires qui sont faites sur les
royalties donc si elle ne vend pas cette
maison selon le magazine Public dont je
ne suis plus là directrice
si elle ne vend pas cette maison
marne-la-coquette va être mise aux
enchères par le fisc voilà donc là
bravo alors on a le spécialiste des
dettes
le spécialiste des recouvrement ici on a
besoin dans l'émission donc le
spécialiste du recouvrement Benjamin
Castaldi qu'est-ce qui te donne je pense
pas qu'elle soit réellement ruinée en
tous les cas ce qui est un peu curieux
c'est que quand on hérite on a un choix
quand on vous dit voilà il y a un
héritage soit tu acceptes l'héritage
avec les dettes et l'actifs qui est
enfin et si en fait l'actif est
supérieur au passif on peut refuser
alors être plus dire je prends rien si
le passif
c'est pour ça que
donc
[Applaudissements]
je comprends que tu sois dans le rouge
explications
la vérité c'est qu'elle a évidemment de
l'argent ailleurs
les sociétés mais qui pour l'instant euh
oui oui il y en a il y en a plus mais
pour l'instant toute cet argent est
bloqué donc si elle ne rembourse pas
comment tu sais toi on est renseigné
avec Bernard on le sait tout le monde le
sait elle a gelé les dettes positif
financier qui existe et pendant 10 ans
de sauvegarde en fait où c'est dettes
sont gelées pendant 10 ans personne peut
lui réclamer ni ses créanciers ni le
risque voilà et là en revanche moi j'ai
rien compris
parce que elle est par exemple cet été
juste un exemple comme ça
c'est un système où je peux les mettre
c'est dur c'est une procédure dite de
sauve j'ai noté parce que c'est assez
j'ai l'impression qu'il y en a qui gèle
les dettes lui cet hiver surtout il va
geler les couilles
derrière c'est un petit soviétique
financier sa procédure de sauvegarde qui
permet à une personne de geler les
dettes pendant 10 ans et à la demander à
l'étalement de ses dettes seulement de
ses dettes à la deuxième chambre du
tribunal du commerce de Paris et du coup
elle va pouvoir établir un échéancier
pour rembourser ses dettes au fur et à
mesure mais ça c'est sur les actifs des
sociétés c'est pas sur ce qu'elle doit
office qu'est-ce que Johnny Hallyday
devait
il était question
le problème de départ vient de là le
problème de départ vient de là c'est
qu'en fait si vous voulez ils ont essayé
d'échapper au fisc français pour être
clair avec ce trust mais manque de pot
le fisc français réclame quand même un
du parce que tout ce qui a gagné Johnny
c'était en France voilà même si la
montée une structure 4-5 sociétés
une société apprêtée à l'autre sans
raison donc bang et le fisc tombe dessus
2 millions et demi non non mais c'est
énorme le truc c'est énorme il y a eu
tout un montage financier complexe
par exemple juste un exemple puisqu'elle
affiche toutes ses vacances Agde chez sa
famille c'est bien Saint-Tropez la Grèce
Saint-Barth elle a quand même deux
maisons à Saint-Barth aussi qui a le
loup 50000 balles la semaine au minimum
on est tout à fait d'accord
elle est quand même assez étranglée
parce que toute cette argent est bloqué
et que aujourd'hui le travail qu'elle
avait avec Johnny on en est loin très
très loin donc non mais voilà c'est sûr
que comparé à nos salaires enfin
toujours allumer le feu
je pose la question
[Applaudissements]
par exemple elle avait la maison la
maison de Pacific palissade la maison de
Johnny qui faisait 1000 mètres carrés
elle a racheté une nouvelle maison
maintenant après avoir une maison
intermédiaire ça c'était la maison du
Pacifique palissac
à l'intérieur et là du coup la changer
là c'est tout noir dedans c'est
magnifique c'était une très belle maison
et la piscine était noire et derrière
toi
tu es nulle part mais qui a été partout
j'y vais moi donc
la piscine on voit la mer on voit
c'était très beau c'est une très belle
maison de cinéma jacuzzi il y avait tout
ça en transport et tout
racheter une maison maintenant 5006 à
peu près sur sur
la neige
là c'est un premier du de 13 millions
comme l'a dit
arrêtez en plus
qu'est-ce qui se passe si elle a pas le
projet
va être vendue aux enchères et elle
n'aura rien dessus
aux impôts alors la maison là voilà la
maison de marne-la-coquette tennis et
tout ça et en fait elle voulait laver en
de 14 millions
estimation et là les prêtes à le vendre
à 5 il y avait huit comment je suis
pressée
qui lui a fait une proposition à 8 à 8
millions 75
sauf que le le monsieur qui voulait la
maison était mis en examen donc
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
immobilier
sur ce dossier elle a organisé une
exposition de Johnny en Belgique payer
quand même 20 € la place
[Rires]
22,50 € et bon là ça va être bien quoi
ce sont les costumes de scène qu'elle
m'aime a racheté et ce que parce que
Johnny se débarrassait de tous les
costumes de scène il y a jamais voulu
les garder et elle à partir de 1995 elle
a gardé tous les costumes de samedi elle
pensait beaucoup c'est pareil avec tous
les chroniqueurs donc je me suis
débarrassé
une exposition à 22,50 € en fait ce qui
hérite profondément le fisc c'est le
rachat de la nouvelle maison parce que
c'est des arrières et d'impôts d'une
tournée de Johnny de 2009-2010 donc
c'est très ancien et le fils qui est au
bout de sa patience donc là ils ont
vraiment dit on va saisir et il y a une
autre affaire derrière c'est quand ils
étaient en exil en Suisse il y a des
arriérés d'impôts là-dessus qui vont
s'ajouter donc ouais donc elle a un
énorme problème de liquidité mais le
fisc lui dit vous nous dites que vous
avez un problème de liquidité pour payer
et vous avez plein de propriétés jusqu'à
raison donc du coup il faut pas la
plaindre mais c'est vrai que là si elle
trouve pas les liquidités tout de suite
ça va être saisi demande la coquette et
peut-être après d'autres biens donc
[Rires]
si vous voulez
l'appeler pour moi de ma coquette maison
on est à quel niveau
c'est beaucoup plus grand là c'est grand
Marnac c'est magnifique
que la vôtre non mais au calme
il faut quand même rappeler qu'elle a
deux maisons à Saint-Barth la maison ça
fait quatre fois que tu le rappelles
mais parce que c'est important
la villa du bas la Villa elles sont
magnifiques ces baraques et donc les
loups là aussi très cher et les loups
d'ailleurs toute l'année elle a raison
est-ce qu'elle veut pas d'argent moi je
la Lourdais toute l'année la maison
parce que en pleine saison par exemple
pour les fêtes de Noël c'est quand même
130 000 euros
hier soir j'ai tapé pour voir alors la
vente de la maison de Joyce c'est shot
bise si ça vous intéresse sauce ouais et
la maison la grande elle est sur villa
rental et dans laquelle tu parles de
quelle maison là
il y en a deux et il y a la maison du
dessous la Villa Joy d'accord qui
appartient aussi bon voilà ils avaient
trouvé des acheteurs
en même temps c'est maison très cher
elle lui coûte aussi beaucoup d'argent
entre deux
c'est sur la baie de Marigot c'est
somptueux la vue sur la mer